next up we have Alex kiesling CEO of
quora computing did I say that right
okay okay analog and digital Quantum
Computing with neutral atoms so we'll
talk thank you very much uh it's very
exciting to be here and be able to share
with you some very recent results from
work that was done both at Harvard and
at cuera
am I working oh I think it I think it is
now
thanks
uh yeah so I'm very happy to be here
sharing some recent results uh on analog
and digital Quantum computation with
neutral atoms that has been done both at
Harvard MIT but also at queera Computing
which is our startup that came out of of
the work that was done here at the
universities
uh I'd like to start by
looking at where we are in terms of
Frontiers in Quantum science and
engineering and uh I'd like to focus on
two key challenges that remain it's a
very exciting time right now of fast and
accelerating progress uh but it is still
the case that building large-scale
control Quantum machines is complicated
and it's a large set of problems that
we're still trying to tackle we see that
there's an inherent tension between
having a high degree of controllability
and the ability to scale up the the
types of systems that we use
while preserving this High degree of
controllability and non-uh either
increasing the the complexity or
decreasing in the in the performance
there's many different platforms that
are approaching this problem from
different angles but there's still a lot
of work to be done here and the second
one is let's say that we have these
machines but the ones that we that exist
today and the ones that we're building
that will exist tomorrow what do we do
with them it's important that as
technology progresses we develop
applications and algorithms that are
producing value from the hardware that
we have accessible nowadays so
our approach to to try to tackle these
uh these challenges is to use neutral
atoms held in Optical tweezers
they they have the ability to be very
well isolated from the environment
giving us access to controlling hundreds
of of atoms all of them identical to one
another with a very well developed
toolbox of initialization State readout
but also introducing controls there is
the ability with this platform to
implement both analog and digital forms
of quantum computation which I will go
into a little bit more detail in a
second
now since Optical optically trapped
neutral atoms don't rely on manufactured
chips we have a lot of flexibility in
how we position atoms relative to one
another and this is important on how
they will interact with one another this
we can do several times a second
changing the properties effectively of
how the the the quantum processor is is
operating
now to understand what neutral atoms Q
Mutual atom qubits are I'll try to give
you a very simple introduction
you can think of a neutral atom as a
two-state system where the electron can
be in one of two states either ground or
what we call Red Brick State and the red
brick state is effectively pulling the
electron far away from the nucleus the
reason why this is important is because
this R State this redberg state gives
atoms the ability to interact with one
another a significant distance
while two atoms in the ground state
unlike many other forms of qubits don't
interact with one another two atoms in
the red brick State interact very
strongly with one another and what that
leads to is this called the so-called
red brick blockade radius and one way to
think about it it's a very useful way to
think about it is that two atoms that
are far away from one another act as
completely isolated two atoms that are
close to one another will only only
allow one of them to be in the red
bricks State at any one time so it's
effectively conditional logic
now taking this from two atoms to many
when we place them on something like
this in a in a square grid we can draw
some connectivity that indicates which
qubits can interact with which other
qubits and this doesn't rely on any form
of cables this is just given by where
are the atoms optically trapped
moreover we can set different conditions
for the interactions of these qubits and
there's this other parameter that is is
the tuning of a laser the important
thing to know about it is that when this
parameter is large and negative we are
basically telling the atoms that being
all in the ground state is fine however
when we put them when we make it large
and positive we're trying to maximize
the number of atoms that can flip their
state to the red brick state but there
is this added constraint of the
connectivity so no two lines that are no
two vertices that are connected by a
line can simultaneously be in the red
brick state so this is just a quick
primer so you understand some of the
results that I'm going to be describing
but this is the basis for a lot of what
the uh of what we do and the combination
of these flexible geometries and the red
brick blockade allows us to look at very
efficient implementation of quantum
simulation and Quantum optimization
algorithms
I'll start by telling you a little bit
about where we we have done on analog
Quantum simulation of topological matter
we just heard a little bit about
topological matter but uh just to
refresh everyone from the last 20
minutes uh topological Quantum matter
particularly is something that is of
large interest to the quantum Computing
Community because it has unique
properties of matter that make it robust
against local noise it has the potential
to open up a very robust form of quantum
computation and the principles behind it
were really described theoretically over
50 years ago but it's taken us until now
to really be able to have concrete
evidence of topological Quantum matter
in the lab
the original idea for this came from uh
from thinking about
spins that are trying to anti-align and
what happens to them when they are in a
frustrated geometry like a triangular
lattice and the discovery here was that
what they will do is they will form
correlations uh across pairs in what are
called dimers and to minimize the
overall energy of the system these
dimers will cover the entire grid by
creating local correlations between
between Pairs and this this complete
covering or dimer covering can take many
different forms and the idea of a
Quantum spin liquid which is a
particular form of topological Quantum
matter is that in which there exists a
macroscopic superposition of all of
these different types of timers
now if you take this idea to a slightly
different configuration not a triangular
lattice but what we know as a Kagome
lattice we can actually enforce the same
kind of condition by making sure that
placing atoms along the the links
between nodes in the Kagome lattice uh
in a way that the rydberg blockade radio
so the the area that that is blocked by
an atom being in the red brick state is
consistent with blocking all possible
other atoms that would extend to uh to
the nodes next to it so maximizing in
this case the number of red brick atoms
uh translates to creating a dimer
covering of this lattice
now the idea here was can we create a
state that
allows us to prepare this macroscopic
superposition of Alzheimer coverings as
you see in the bottom and this is what
we set out to do for ourselves in the
lab
and the protocol that we used was
let's initialize all the atoms in their
ground state and slowly nudge them
towards preferring to be in the red
brick state so that we we
adiabatically move into a state where
the ground state is this subset of
Alzheimer coverings and as a function of
of the parameter that we were scanning
we can see that there's a particular
string order correlator that tells us
whether we are within the dimer space or
how close we are to to being fully in
the dimer space
and we see that this particular metric
for larger and larger many body uh
correlators uh still gives us a
measurable signal for uh for parts of
the system that are of of a quite a
large size of of the entire system now
this tells us something about the the
one basis basically are we creating
things in this dimer state but it could
be that it's the same one over and over
again or that there's a few different
states within this that are being
selected or that it's a classical a
classical mixture however by inducing
Dynamics we can actually probe the
coherence between all of these dimer
substrates subsets
and we can recover a measurable signal
for uh within the same parameter regime
for Loops of of uh again very large
slices so this tells us that yes we are
preparing something that is within the
the timer Subspace and that it is a
coherent superposition of all of these
different combinations so this is a
direct measurement of a string car
correlator for a topological Quantum
phase of matter
uh this was something that we were
working towards but it actually led to
the to a an unexpected discovery that
this phase is actually quite robust in
in a situation that is away from
equilibrium so not necessarily the the
exact ground state of the system but it
dynamically prepared state that is uh
that is metastable for uh for a very
long time
hmm
now taking this idea further what
happens when we change the topology of
the system and we make it non-trivial
yeah make sure I understood that last
statement so uh were you saying that you
first checked in equilibrium that you
saw the string order parameter it was
stable and then you sort of just to push
it further you went far away from
equilibrium to see if it survived and
then it survived is that actually
actually the the statement here is
slightly different what's that
um calculating the ground states of
these systems is non-trivial especially
given to size but whatever calculating
you mean preparing in yourself
calculating calculating classical to try
to predict what is the exact right but
what we've noticed is that
when doing simulations in smaller system
sizes which are consistent with the
experimental data the the exact ground
state of the system uh deviates from
this and the region where it it behaves
as a Quantum spin liquid is actually
narrower than what we see so the the
dynamic preparation of it puts a system
in a state that is not exactly the
ground state a slightly higher energy
states
meaning that it is out of equilibrium
but it actually has a much stronger
overlap with the quantum and liquid
state
but the thing you're measuring is that
you I mean at some level you don't
actually care exactly what state it's in
just as long as it has the string or the
parameters okay yeah
now going to uh that question like your
strings uh your expected value of x here
is like decaying exponentially
relationship
s or uh some of it is measurement noise
and the fact that we're not measuring in
exactly the right basis uh some of it is
that there is a finite uh density of
monomers so this would be Alzheimer's
but there is a finite density of monomer
is it in the preparation and there's
actually uh
the way that this decays is is well
explained by the the finite density of
monomers
all right so moving on to a less trivial
topology where we have a hole we can now
actually Identify two different distinct
topological subspaces that are not
connected by any local uh local
modifications so any type of local
error can move us within one of the
manifolds but not between them and in
this way we can define a zero and one
logical
subspaces for the uh for the system that
we have here and this can be the
beginning of a topological Quantum bit
we we see that even in this non-trivial
topology the the the kinds of behaviors
that I was describing are still present
there and that through this dynamical
preparation we can initialize a state
that is consistent with the zero plus
one state the X State
there's a lot more work to be done here
and there is a lot more work that we are
doing to understand how to how to adjust
the the dynamical preparation but this
is a very encouraging start to start
exploring how to how to prepare and use
topological Quantum bits
I'm going to shift gears now and sorry
that I'm speaking so fast I have a lot
of material that I want to get through
to encourage a lot of questions uh
during the networking session I'm going
to move on to a different application
that uses very similar tools and I'm
just going to use a different language
instead of looking at Quantum problems I
am now looking at how how well can
Quantum Hardware be used to solve
classical problems particularly in
combinatorial optimization and for this
I'm going to focus on the maximum
independent set problem this is uh a
specific graph problem that given a
graph like this one with a set of nodes
and and edges connecting them the
problem is simply stated as
finding or coloring the largest number
of nodes so that no two of them are
connected by an edge and this type of uh
of problem finding the maximum
Independence said well it's very easy to
explain in principle what the problem is
solving it can become very very hard in
fact it is a NP complete problem
uh so it's you can think of it as a
library of problems or a language in
which we can express many different
problems
this the the the the kind of graph that
I have here is a specific type of graph
known as a unit disk graph uh and the
unit disk graph is defined by
all nodes that are within a unit
distance of one another will share an
edge but anything past that unit
distance is it does not have an edge so
in in a way this is a local type of
graph
the unit this graph now I want to point
out that this is exactly the same
connectivity constraint that I gave for
having atoms within a 2d geometry where
the unit distance is given precisely by
the by the blockade radius size
turns out that this is still an NP hard
problem to solve
approximating it is easier than than
approximating generic graphs but again
finding Solutions efficiently for this
would of course be amazing
Now using that uh
what we do is we have now a way to
encode problems right we have a way of
creating these unit disk graphs uh and
we have a way of initializing uh
effectively the all zero state
and to try to solve the problem not just
encoded what we use is again this this
slow changing of our control parameter
Delta that takes us from one ground
state with all atoms in the in the
electronic ground state to maximizing
the number of red brick states meaning
exactly the Mis by parametrizing this
this evolution in a piecewise linear way
we can throw this into a closed loop
Optimizer where
a machine a computer is telling the the
quantum processor to initialize a
particular graph this is a Kings graph
implement the quantum Evolution and then
take a measurement then from this
measurement or really a set of multiple
measurements with the same protocol we
can extract a figure of Merit that is
then put within a a closed loop
Optimizer that then changes the
variational parameters of that pulse
that you see on the left to give us
better and better performance and this
is what it looks like not exactly in
real time but this is what what the
machine would do we we let it sit no
one's touching it no one's close to it
it's just doing its own thing uh without
any human intervention until it starts
finding better and better Solutions when
you see there at the bottom is the
figure of Merit getting better and
better over time
using this we can find
good waveforms that allow us to get
better approximations and we can test
those on many different
graph instances of different sizes and
also by varying the total Evolution time
what you're seeing here is taking four
different graph instances and running
this on the quantum Hardware but also
using simulated annealing uh in the
initial portion of it uh the the high
energy we see that this is uh the
behavior is is basically the same across
the board however uh
for for the different graph instances
the behavior as we start getting closer
and closer to the good Solutions uh
changes from instance to instance and
interestingly we see that for the
classical algorithm uh specifically the
the simulated annealing we see that it
can get stuck at near Optimal Solutions
and the way that we understood this is
to think about how many near Optimal
Solutions there are versus how many
Optimal Solutions there are and how are
they connected and from this we can
extract the single number that we call
the hardness parameter that tells us How
likely is it that the classical
algorithm will get stuck in in one of
these sub-optimal Solutions so we can
now use this to re-parametrize all of
the different graphs in different sizes
as a function of their hardness
parameter
for the yeah the output of this uh of
your computation is not a specific uh
maximal independent stuff but rather an
estimate the independence number it is
it is an independent set oh you do and
then we measure so what it what it looks
like is effectively like this and what
we do is that we measure how many red
circles we have and then we say there
were you know
right like well uh for for the
optimization we take the average over
multiple iterations because the max is
much more susceptible to noise but
eventually if you're running this to get
the best the best solution that you can
you will take the max okay that's what
it is yeah
so for the quantum algorithm what we
what we found is that rather than
depending uh if just on this hardness
parameter it actually depends as many of
you may expect on how the Gap closes
throughout this transition and the the
experiment is actually quite susceptible
to this it's information that we can
extract directly from the experiment
without having to calculate it
numerically
from that we see that when we when we
look at the size of the Gap that we're
crossing when the the evolution of the
of the circuit is long enough that it
becomes susceptible to that to that Gap
then we see a land landauzener scaling
however if the the the the circuit is
too shallow and we effectively don't see
the whole graph then the performance of
it is is basically the same across the
board and it's you know it's limited to
to
here it's I don't know 0.05 or so
now
when we take this into consideration and
we we look at our two benchmarks
classical and Quantum we see that if we
take the whole data set the classical
and Quantum seem to scale in the same
way as a function of this hardness
parameter but if we focus on the quantum
instances where we know we were able to
row to run a deep enough circuit we
actually see a super linear nearly
quadratic speed up uh in in the Deep
circuit regime and this these particular
results have a product of the size of
the graph to the the depth of the
circuit uh exceeding 2000 so this is
already telling us something that is
very hard to predict numerically with
classical systems
we're using simulated annealing with
quarter latest uh oh this is so this is
classical oh sorry correct yeah I
thought this was a separate Quantum
thing oh no no sorry sorry this is okay
we're using a very generic uh classical
okay
so these two results in analog uh
operation that I showed were performed
on a machine that exists on Harvard but
we're taking this now out of the
university and into the commercial realm
to make it available to everyone uh and
at quora we just finished uh
okay all the tests on our first machine
called aqua level which gives you access
to the same capabilities that we just
heard about and as of two weeks ago you
can access it on the cloud uh we hope
that this is helpful for your research
and that you can now use this as a
platform to develop your own algorithms
uh the way to program it is simple it's
you you define the the geometry the
evolution of the hamiltonian and then
run the program and analyze your data
for more information we're going to have
a webinar this upcoming Monday and for
those of you interested in running
anything on on the machine I must say
that AWS provides research grants for
this
I'm going to very quickly shift gears
again and tell you about another
Direction where we're taking things uh
and this is in digital Quantum
computation and really thinking towards
Quantum error correction how we're going
to get there uh so the the key idea
behind this is to now rethink this
reconfigurability of the of the
connectivity uh not just at the
beginning of the of the calculation but
also throughout and the way that we do
this is we know that we can create
entanglement between Pairs of atoms by
using uh logic gates and by having atoms
across a 2d plane we can bring pairs of
atoms together create entanglement and
then we can actually map the quantum
information in the gr states that I have
mentioned to two hyperfined states that
allow us to preserve the memory there
for over a second we can then use
Optical tweezers to move them around
reconnect and then apply another set of
entangling gates to now connect very
different parts of the processor
uh using this approach we can generate
long-range entanglement using only local
Gates and atom transport and this has
applications in many different
directions including error correction
but also hybrid analog digital uh
architecture
the one example that I want to share
with you on this is how we prepare a
torque uh atori code on a on an actual
Taurus by moving atoms around and the
way that the story code is is done is
with 16 data qubits and AIDS and solar
qubits here the unsolid qubits are in
red and what you're going to see them do
is
Implement Gates between the Ancilla and
the data qubits move them around and by
the end of this we can separate the
Ancilla qubits and be left only with the
data qubits the next steps here are to
to do real-time measurement and feed
forward but at least for now we can do a
measurement at the end where we can
extract all of the
all of the stabilizers and using that
information do Quantum error detection
and see the performance across the two
different encoded logical bits and what
we see of course is that the one that
has the the longer support has better
performance at the shorter one so this
is now already a platform that allows us
to compare side by side uh different
Quantum error correction algorithms in
in our in our search for new and more
efficient ones uh this includes things
like hypergraph and ldpc codes that have
been very hard to implement with any
other kind of hardware
um the last thing is we're look we're
working towards enhanced controllability
and we're looking at a future with
thousands of atoms that we can move and
efficiently uh Implement gates with and
now what we're working towards is to
make the controls uh more sophisticated
and more controlled and for this we're
developing photonic integrated circuit
solutions that give us performance that
is better than anything that has been
reported in the visible range for
optically addressing individual atoms
and building these tools in a scalable
way and this is a little snapshot of
what an early prototype of our devices
looked like and you can see that uh we
can we can modulate individual channels
actually very quickly with this device
I'm going to leave things there and just
thank everyone that has been part of
this big adventure both at Harvard and
at cuera and open the room for questions
so in the first half of your talk it was
basically building an optimization
machine
it seems like uh lately we've had a lot
of classical optimization machines do we
need to bring quantum mechanics in uh is
the advantage going to be big enough
we don't know but I think that the
most I can say is that we will not know
until we build these devices and start
working
there is it's more than than an
Optimizer uh it can do
in a prepared Quantum states that have
nothing to do with optimization and it
also look at dynamics of quantum States
so it's actually much more powerful
Optimizer but I think about the use
cases synthesization are the prevalent
enough that it is worth asking another
question how how how can we leverage
Quantum devices to get better